This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. Parents, at least of a certain era, used to tell their kids, if you can't say anything nice, don't say anything at all. Such advice might seem quaint today. No matter where we look, it can feel as if we're living in a time of mounting incivility. Smart phones and social media amplify this feeling. It used to be that when two people got into an argument in a parking lot or on an airplane, only a few people heard it. But today, thousands of people witnessed rude interactions among people they'll never
这里是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。家长们（至少在某个时代）过去常常对孩子们说：“如果你说不出什么好听的话，就什么也别说。”如今，这样的建议似乎显得有些过时。无论我们看向哪里，都会觉得我们正生活在一个无礼现象日益增加的时代。智能手机和社交媒体放大了这种感觉。过去，当两个人在停车场或飞机上争吵时，只有少数人能听到。但今天，成千上万的人目睹了陌生人之间粗鲁的互动，而这些人他们永远
meet. It's become the stuff of viral videos and memes. We're not talking to you. We're not talking to you. Why don't you mind your own business? We're not talking to you. We're not talking to you. We're not talking to you.
不会再见面。这已经成了病毒式视频和表情包的素材。我们没跟你说话。我们没跟你说话。你为什么不多管管你自己的闲事？我们没跟你说话。我们没跟你说话。我们没跟你说话。
We're not talking to you. We're not talking to you. We're not talking to you. We're not talking to you. We're not easy to do and that rudeness has a long-lasting malevolent power. We're flooded with emotions and that's when this fight or flight gear kicks in. You know, one way that I think about this is like the storm inside your brain. The surprising effects of instability and how to protect yourself from its toxic influence. This week on Hidden Brain.
我们没跟你说话。我们没跟你说话。我们没跟你说话。我们没跟你说话。我们没那么容易做到，而且这种粗鲁具有持久的恶性力量。我们被各种情绪淹没，正是在那时，这种战斗或逃跑的机制开始启动。你知道，我思考这个问题的一个方式，就像你大脑内部的一场风暴。不稳定性带来的惊人影响以及如何保护自己免受其毒害。本周的《隐形大脑》。
Rudeness and instability seem to be showing up everywhere these days, on airplanes, in supermarket aisles, in restaurants. What effect does this tide of nastiness have on all of us? According to the old adage, sticks and stones may break my bones, but words will never hurt me. But is this really true? At Georgetown University, behavioral scientist Christine Porath studies the effects of incivility on our communities, our careers, even our capacity for creativity. Christine Porath, welcome to Hidden Brain.
如今，粗鲁和不稳定似乎无处不在：在飞机上、在超市过道里、在餐馆里。这种令人厌恶的风气对我们所有人都产生了什么影响？根据那句老话：棍棒和石头可能会骨折，但言语永远不会伤害我。但事实真的如此吗？在乔治敦大学，行为科学家克里斯蒂·波拉思研究了无礼对我们的社区、我们的职业甚至我们的创造力的影响。克里斯蒂·波拉思，欢迎来到《隐形大脑》。
Thanks for having me. I want to start by having you tell me about a moment in your own life, Christine, where you saw the effects of incivility first hand. You were still a student in college when you received word that your dad was in the hospital. Can you describe the scene for me when you got there? Well, I remember vividly walking up to the hospital room and being in the doorway and seeing him lying there
谢谢邀请我来。我想先请你讲讲你自己生活中的一个时刻，克里斯蒂，你亲眼目睹了无礼的影响。当时你还是个大学生，突然接到消息说你父亲住院了。当你赶到那里时，能为我描述一下当时的场景吗？嗯，我清晰地记得自己走到病房门口，看到他躺在那里
in the hospital bed with electrodes strapped to his bare chest. And it was shocking for me to see him like that because he was an otherwise, you know, very strong, vivacious, athletic guy. And I had never envisioned something like that happening to him. Why was he in the hospital? Well, he had had a heart attack and this stemmed from working for a very toxic boss. He had actually worked for two toxic bosses for over the course of a decade. And it was really coming to a breaking point.
病床上的光胸膛上绑着电极。看到他那样让我感到震惊，因为在其他方面，你知道，他是一个非常强壮、充满活力、热爱运动的人。我从未想过这种事会发生在他身上。他为什么住院？嗯，他心脏病发作了，这源于为一位非常刻薄的老板工作。实际上，在过去十多年里，他一直为两位刻薄的老板工作。这真的到了崩溃的边缘。
And it wasn't until I bought a decade later or more that he shared some of the particulars and really spoke openly about that. And the truth was, it was painful for him to relive that stuff. Christine's father was a salesman. His boss would insult staff members in meetings and blame them for things beyond their control. He even belittled clients. During a visit to a client store,
直到十年或更久之后，我买下了它，他才分享了一些细节，并真正公开谈论了那件事。事实是，对重温那些事情对他是痛苦的。克里斯蒂的父亲是一名销售员。他的老板会在会议上侮辱员工，并将他们无法控制的事情归咎于他们。他甚至贬低客户。在拜访客户商店期间，
my dad heard his boss tell the owner, I see you're carrying on your father's tradition. The store looked like sh** then, During a visit to a client store, my dad heard his boss tell the owner, I see you're carrying on your father's tradition. The store looked like sh** then and it looks like sh** in your hands. The idea of people being put on the spot was something in a meeting, you know, you don't know what you're doing here.
我父亲听到他的老板对店主说：“我看得出来你在继承你父亲的传统。那时的商店看起来像狗屎一样，在拜访客户商店期间，我父亲听到他的老板对店主说：‘我看得出来你在继承你父亲的传统。那时的商店看起来像狗屎一样，现在在你手里看起来也像狗屎。’这种让人当众出丑的想法，就像在会议上一样，‘你不知道你在这里做什么。’”
Screaming certainly took place, which I would say like crosses the line of what I tend to study. So some years later you were working at your first job. It was at a sports academy in Florida. An incident took place early one morning before work at the company Jim. Can you paint me a picture of what happened, Christine? My friend who ran the Performance Institute, he would open it up early for us to work out before the gym was open to athletes. And, you know, he would have music playing in the background, kind of energetic, workout
尖叫声确实发生了，这可以说是超越了我倾向于研究的界限。所以几年后你在你的第一份工作。那是在佛罗里达州的一家体育学院。上班前的一天清晨，在公司的健身房发生了一起事件。克里斯蒂，你能给我描绘一下发生了什么吗？我的朋友经营着这家表现研究所，他会早早开门让我们在健身房对运动员开放之前锻炼。而且，你知道，他会放背景音乐，那种充满活力、锻炼用的
music. And we'd all be doing our thing on the treadmills and somewhere lifting weights. And ironically, the person whose name was on the sports agency showed up. And oftentimes, he was out of town traveling the world. So this was unexpected. And he just started screaming at the performance manager, saying, you know that I love Barry White. Why isn't my music playing?
音乐。我们都会在跑步机上做自己的事情，有些人在举重。具有讽刺意味的是，这家体育机构挂名的人出现了。通常情况下，他都在外地环游世界。所以这是意料之外的。他只是开始对表现经理大喊大叫，说：“你知道我喜欢巴里·怀特。为什么不放我的音乐？”
So my friend went in the back and changed the music to a very white. And then we all kind of put our heads down and people's minds were swirling a little bit in terms of what they had just witnessed and why that happened and what did that mean for them during the day. But the biggest thing I think was just the way that it affected people's emotions and moods and they weren't themselves. They didn't bring the same energy to the athletes or the customers or the people that they were dealing with that day.
所以我的朋友去后面把音乐换成了巴里·怀特。然后我们都低下了头，大家的脑子里都在胡思乱想，想着他们刚刚目睹了什么，为什么会这样，这对他们白天的生活意味着什么。但我认为最重要的事情是它影响人们情绪和心情的方式，他们不再是自己了。他们没有把同样的精力带给那天他们要应付的运动员、顾客或人们。
I want to talk about one of the story that reveals what it feels like to be directly on the receiving end of Incivility. Some years after you left the Sports Academy in Florida, you became an academic, you were a junior professor at a school, and you had an encounter with a senior professor at a holiday party. Can you tell me what happened? We were talking just kind of over in the corner, and he said that he thought my book had a stupid thing title. And, you know, I didn't really know what to say in response to that. I just kind of took it, but I really just wanted to escape the situation. And I certainly didn't ask for his opinion about the title. So it really took me off track, because I remember, you know, days afterwards,
我想谈谈另一个故事，它揭示了直接成为无礼承受者的感受。在你离开佛罗里达州的体育学院几年后，你成为了一名学者，你在某所学校担任初级教授，在一个节日派对上，你偶遇了一位资深教授。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？我们当时只是在角落里聊天，他说他觉得我的书名起得很蠢。而且，你知道，我真的不知道该怎么回应。我只是默默承受了，但我真的很想逃离那个处境。我当然没有征求他对书名的意见。所以这真的让我有些崩溃，因为我记得，你知道，几天之后，
kind of sitting in my office, staring at the computer screen, and just thinking about that. And would it meant for the prospects of my career, because I was up for tenure? And our profession, that means like you're up or out, you either have a job or you're going to lose that job and need to uproot yourself and your whole life from that place.
我坐在办公室里，盯着电脑屏幕，脑子里一直在想这件事。这对我未来的职业前景意味着什么，因为我当时正在争取终身教职？在我们的行业里，这意味着“要么晋升，要么走人”，要么你保住工作，要么你就会失去工作，不得不拔根连基，离开那个地方，改变你整个人生。
So I felt like I had a lot riding on it, and given that he had a lot of power and status and everything else, I just wondered what that meant for me in my future. I'm wondering how you behaved around the senior professor. You must have bumped into him in the hallways or past him at meetings, or did it change your behavior and how you interact with him going forward? Yeah, definitely changed my behavior. I really tried to avoid him and work with my office or clothes. I really almost like timed when I would go to the bathroom to avoid people.
所以我感觉自己压上了很多筹码，考虑到他拥有很大的权力和地位以及其他一切，我只是想知道这对我和我的未来意味着什么。我想知道你在面对这位资深教授时的表现。你一定在走廊里偶遇过他，或者在会议上擦肩而过，这是否改变了你的行为以及你以后与他互动的方式？是的，这绝对改变了我的行为。我真的尽量避开他，把办公室的门关上。我甚至几乎像掐着时间去洗手间来避开其他人。
I think that I kind of became a shell of myself around him and other people. So that single moment of Incivility stayed with you for a long time. And it makes me think about the long term effects of all the rudeness we see around us. It does seem as though there has been an increase in Incivility, perhaps as the COVID pandemic has worn us all down. In January 2022, a customer at a smoothie shop in Fairfield, Connecticut received the wrong drink. He claimed it contained peanut butter and he said his son had had an allergic reaction and needed to be hospitalized.
我觉得在他和其他人面前，我变得有点像个空壳了。因此，那单一的无礼时刻伴随了你很长时间。这让我思考我们周围所有粗鲁行为的长期影响。看起来无礼现象确实有所增加，也许是因为新冠大流行让我们所有人都感到身心俱疲。2022年1月，康涅狄格州费尔菲尔德一家冰沙店的顾客拿错了饮料。他声称里面含有花生酱，并说他的儿子有过敏反应需要住院治疗。
The man confronted two young employees at the smoothie shop, calling one of them an immigrant loser. The exchange, which is really quite disturbing to hear when viral on social media. What? Shut up. Who are you? F**king immigrant loser. What are you? Get the f**k out. Get the f**k out.
这名男子与冰沙店的两名年轻员工发生了争执，称其中一人为“移民失败者”。这段在社交媒体上疯传的对话听起来确实令人不安。什么？闭嘴。你算什么东西？他妈的移民失败者。你是什么？给老子滚出去。给老子滚出去。
Christine, it could be that we're hearing about incidents like this because of social media, but it does feel like almost every other week brings a new example of people simply losing it. Do you think there is more incivility around us these days? I do, unfortunately, and our and other research would suggest that the number one reason for incivility is that people feel stressed or overwhelmed. I think that, you know, unfortunately, that kind of negativity, even around, you know,
克里斯蒂，我们之所以听到这样的事件，可能是因为社交媒体的传播，但感觉几乎每隔一周就会出现一个新的例子，展示人们彻底失控。你认为如今我们身边的无礼现象更多了吗？不幸的是，确实如此。我们的研究和其他研究表明，无礼的首要原因是人们感到压力巨大或不堪重负。我认为，不幸的是，这种消极情绪，甚至围绕着
the pandemic, around politics, around uncertainty, leads us to feel more stressed and is a reason that at least people say caused their rudeness or responding negatively in moments like those. Healthcare systems in particular, it's just terrible these days and CEOs of hospitals, some of them have reached out to me and said, do you know how bad it is right now? And I think just like this clip eludes to, a lot of this is mixed with racism and politics. So they are on the front lines of getting this.
大流行、政治、不确定性的消极情绪，让我们感到压力更大，这也是人们将之归咎于自己粗鲁或在这些时刻做出消极反应的原因。医疗系统尤其如此，现在的情况真是糟透了，一些医院的首席执行官甚至联系我说：“你知道现在情况有多糟糕吗？”我认为就像这个视频片段所暗示的那样，很多这种情况都与种族主义和政治交织在一起。所以他们正处于承受这一切的最前线。
And it's just become really, really hard for them. When we come back, the surprisingly powerful effects that instability has on our brains and what we can do about it, you're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. If you recently had a stand in a long line at the airport, or waited for a bus that never showed up, or had to deal with an incompetent customer service rep in a call center, you may have felt a rising level of impatience. It may have taken all your effort to keep your frustrations under control.
对他们来说，这已经变得非常非常艰难。稍后回来，不稳定性对我们大脑产生的惊人强大影响以及我们可以采取的应对措施。您正在收听的是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。如果你最近在机场排过长队，或者苦等一辆从未出现的公交车，或者不得不应付呼叫中心里一个不称职的客服代表，你可能会感到不耐烦的情绪正在上升。你可能耗费了全部精力才把沮丧情绪控制住。
Many of us can think of situations where we lost it, or where we saw others lose their cool. Social media is full of videos showing people screaming at each other in stores, in restaurants, and in workplaces. At Georgetown University, behavioral scientists Christine Porath studies the effects of this tide of incivility. Christine, when you were in high school, you played on a boy's soccer team, and I understand that at the time, you felt that the best way to deal with root-ness was just to shake it off? Yeah, well, I think just coming from that background,
我们许多人都能想到自己失控的场景，或者看到其他人失去冷静的场景。社交媒体上到处都是视频，展示人们在商店、餐馆和工作场所互相尖叫。在乔治敦大学，行为科学家克里斯蒂·波拉思研究了这股无礼浪潮的影响。克里斯蒂，当你上高中时，你曾在一个男子足球队踢球，我听说当时你觉得应对粗鲁的最佳方式就是抖落掉它，别放在心上？是的，嗯，我觉得正是由于那种背景，
it's the idea that you should be strong and rise above it and just power through. And so we're shaped by our background and our experiences. And so that's what I brought to the table. And especially when it came to me and those that I was close to, it was like, come on, suck it up, or just rise above it, get over it, but definitely playing boys high school soccer.
那种想法就是你应该坚强，超越它，咬牙坚持过去。因此，我们由我们的背景和经历塑造。这就是我带来的东西。尤其是当涉及到我和我亲近的人时，感觉就像是“得了吧，振作起来，或者超越它，克服它”，但绝对是在踢男子高中足球时。
I did stand out, even had the long ponytail on all. And so in some ways I felt tested that I definitely should be strong and hold my own within that environment. So we discussed how when a senior colleague disparaged your book title, you founded a heart lasted a very long time. And you yourself were studying the phenomenon of instability, along with your colleague Christine Pearson, you've asked people about their experiences with rudeness and instability. What do
我确实很显眼，甚至还留着长马尾辫。所以在某种程度上，我觉得自己受到了考验，我绝对应该在这个环境中保持坚强并站稳脚跟。所以我们讨论了当一位资深同事贬低你的书名时，你发现这种伤害持续了很长一段时间。你和你的同事克里斯蒂·皮尔森一直在研究这种不稳定性现象，你们询问了人们关于他们遭受粗鲁和不稳定性对待的经历。人们
people tell you about the effects that mistreatment has had on them? What we found is that it stuck and was much more painful than we would have anticipated. I remember incidents like there was one person who had worked in a little league baseball concession stand and you know he remembers being belittled afterwards he actually had to go to the owner of this team's house and explain you know a mistake and got screamed at and 17 years later he's writing about it and says he thinks about it and so those were the kind of things that stuck I think we had someone report something from 1988 when they were sitting around a table with 12 peers and got treated in a way that they felt dismissed and belittled. And so you had people that were
对这种虐待对他们的影响说了些什么？我们发现，它挥之不去，而且比我们预期的要痛苦得多。我记得一些事件，比如曾有一个人在小联盟棒球特许经营摊位工作，你知道，他记得之后受到贬低，他实际上不得不去这个球队老板家里解释一个错误，结果被狠狠地大吼大叫。17年后，他还在写这件事，并说他依然会想起它。所以这些就是那些挥之不去的事情。我想我们曾有人报告过1988年的事情，当时他们和12位同龄人坐在一张桌子旁，受到的对待让他们感到被解雇和贬低。所以你会发现有人
holding on to these experiences for not just months or years, but decades. I want to examine both the immediate effects of instability on the mind, as well as some of these long-term effects that you're talking about. You see that instability can hijack the amygdala. What do you mean by this, Christine? Well, I think it means that we're flooded with emotions, and that's when kind of this idea of fight or flight to gear kicks in, and it leads to us for many people being paralyzed almost in terms of not being able to respond to things or not being able to react or making changes that would help us in that moment.
对这些经历念念不忘，不是几个月或几年，而是几十年。我想探讨不稳定对思维的即时影响，以及你所谈到的一些长期影响。你发现不稳定可以劫持杏仁核。克里斯蒂，你这是什么意思？嗯，我认为这意味着我们被情绪淹没，正是在那时，这种战斗或逃跑的机制开始启动，导致许多人几乎陷入瘫痪，无法对事情做出回应，无法做出反应，也无法做出能在那一刻帮助我们的改变。
Like it's almost as if we can't cope with the situation because we're struggling to process things. And so one way that I think about this is like the storm inside your brain. Christina's conducted many studies into the effects of instability. One of them builds on a famous psychological experiment. Volunteers are asked to watch a video of people rapidly passing a basketball.
就像我们几乎无法应对这种局面，因为我们在努力处理事情。所以我想象这种情况的一个方式就像你大脑内部的一场风暴。克里斯蒂对不稳定的影响进行了多项研究。其中一项研究建立在一个著名的心理实验基础之上。志愿者被要求观看一段人们快速传篮球的视频。
Right in the middle of the game, a person wearing a gorilla's suit walks through the middle of the frame. Many volunteers fail to notice the gorilla because they are so focused on the ball being passed. In Christine's experiment, she exposed a subset of volunteers to incivility before they watched the video. And they were five times less likely to see the gorilla on the screen. And that really surprised us. But also with other studies, what we found is that it took people a lot longer to answer questions, to solve anagrams, were jumbles to create words. They had much more difficulty doing that kind of
就在比赛进行到中间时，一个穿着大猩猩服装的人从画面中央走过。许多志愿者没有注意到大猩猩，因为他们太专注于传球了。在克里斯蒂的实验中，她在志愿者观看视频之前让他们接触了无礼行为。结果，他们看到屏幕上大猩猩的几率低了五倍。这确实让我们感到惊讶。但从其他研究中，我们还发现，人们回答问题、解字谜或拼字游戏所需的时间要长得多。他们在做那种事情时遇到了更多的困难，
thing, so cognitive performance went down significantly. Roughly about 30% across different studies, and even their physical moves to answer questions that was slower. So it seemed to be affecting people in all sorts of ways and what's interesting also is that people weren't aware of this. There's been some work that you and others have done looking at the effects of instability on memory. What do you find? We find that when people are witness rudeness they are far less likely to be able to remember things. So they make a lot more errors. We measured this with math errors, we measured this with performance errors on cognitive tests and the differences were really stunning
因此认知表现显著下降。在不同的研究中，大约下降了30%，甚至他们回答问题的身体动作也变慢了。所以它似乎在各种方面影响着人们，而且有趣的是，人们对此并没有意识到。你和其他人做过一些关于不稳定对记忆影响的研究。你发现了什么？我们发现，当人们目睹粗鲁行为时，他们记住事情的能力就会大大降低。所以他们会犯更多的错误。我们用数学错误来衡量这一点，我们用认知测试中的表现错误来衡量这一点，仅仅是看到或身处这种环境中，
with just seeing this or being around it. You've even found that instability has effects on our creativity, which I found really surprising. What do you find Christine? Yeah, well, we find again, whether you experience instability, whether you witness it, it decreases your ability to come up with creative ideas. So in some of the tests, we give them this study where they come up with as many ideas for what to do with a brick as possible.
差异就真的非常惊人。你甚至发现不稳定对我们的创造力有影响，这让我感到非常惊讶。克里斯蒂，你发现了什么？是的，我们再次发现，无论你经历不稳定还是目睹不稳定，它都会降低你产生创意想法的能力。因此，在某些测试中，我们在研究中让他们尽可能多地想出砖头的用途。
And we code it for dysfunctional ideas, as well as like how creative the ideas are. And what we find is the people that were exposed to rudeness, they come up with really dysfunctional responses for what you do with a brick. Like they will say things like break someone's nose, smash someone's fingers, beat a crush a person to death, sink a body in a river, throw it through a window,
然后我们对其进行编码，分为功能失调的想法以及想法的创造性程度。我们发现的是，那些接触过粗鲁行为的人，他们对砖头的用途想出了非常功能失调的回应。比如他们会说诸如“打破某人的鼻子，砸碎某人的手指，把人殴打或压死，把尸体沉入河中，把它扔过窗户，
place it on the floor to stub people's toe, or something like that. It almost seems as if people are coming up with creative use for the break that are somewhat aggressive. Yeah, scary aggressive. And it was just stunning to see the ideas that people came up with because really all that they were exposed to was just one quick incident. It was like a fleeting moment that they were exposed to. And somehow this is what they came up with.
把它放在地板上踩别人的脚趾”之类的话。这几乎看起来人们想出了对砖头的创造性用途，但这些用途带有某种攻击性。是的，吓人的攻击性。看到人们想出的这些主意真是令人震惊，因为实际上他们所接触的只是一个短暂的事件。就像他们经历了一个稍纵即逝的时刻。而不知何故，这就是他们想出的东西。
Why do you think rudeness has these effects on creativity, both in some ways limiting how creative we can be, but also perhaps exacerbating this kind of aggressive creativity? I think it ties to the hijacking people's focus and attention and the lack of awareness around that. People become much more self-focused, much less other focused. And I think our mind is wrapped up on replaying the incident where they're not focusing on the task nearly as much.
你认为为什么粗鲁会对创造力产生这些影响，一方面限制了我们的创造力，另一方面又可能加剧这种攻击性的创造力？我认为这与劫持人们的注意力和焦点以及对此缺乏意识有关。人们变得更加关注自我，而对他人关注减少。我认为我们的脑海里一直在回放那个事件，以至于他们对任务本身的关注大大减少了。
They're overwhelmed by other thoughts. And so it's very hard to think about anything else. Yeah. We've looked at several effects of instability at the level of our personal psychology, but you found that instability also affects organizational functioning. Can you tell me how rudeness affects loyalty and commitment in the workplace? When people are around cultures where rudeness is prevalent, they're much less likely to want to stick around. So 12% of people who experience sensibility
他们被其他想法压得喘不过气来，所以很难去想别的事情。是的。我们探讨了不稳定在个人心理层面上的几种影响，但你发现不稳定也会影响组织的功能。你能告诉我们粗鲁是如何影响工作场所的忠诚度和承诺的吗？当人们身处粗鲁盛行的文化环境时，他们更不愿意留下来。因此，经历过无礼对待的人中有12%
say that they change jobs as a result of that experience. But also, I think that what we saw is customers that witnessed this kind of behavior, even among, you know, an employee acting rudely to another employee. They were far less likely to want to use that restaurant or that bank, and they were far less loyal to the brand moving forward. When when instability is present, people who work together are also less likely to trust one another. Can you talk about this idea, the effects of rudeness on trust? When you see rudeness, we tend to think, you know, really negative thoughts about that person, I think, and many cases we question their character and their integrity.
表示他们因此换了工作。同时，我也认为我们看到的是，目睹这种行为的顾客（即使是一个员工对另一个员工表现得粗鲁），也远不太愿意光顾那家餐馆或那家银行，而且他们在未来对该品牌的忠诚度也大大降低。当不稳定存在时，一起工作的同事彼此信任的可能性也会降低。你能谈谈这个想法吗？粗鲁对信任的影响。当你看到粗鲁时，我们往往会对那个人产生非常负面的想法，我认为，在许多情况下，我们会质疑他们的品格和正直。
We generalize to a lot of different negative traits because of that one incident. And so that really hurts that person. Then I think we also tend to become less trusting in our own environment. Like for example, we're less likely to speak up in a meeting. Maybe even when that person is in present, because it kind of has shut us down, and we operate much more from a place of fear, we don't offer up ideas. We don't speak up about errors or potential mistakes because we're afraid of the pushback on us.
因为这单一的事件，我们会概括出许多不同的负面特质。所以这确实伤害了那个人。然后我认为我们往往也会对自己的环境变得不那么信任。例如，我们不太可能在会议上发言。甚至可能当那个人不在场时也是如此，因为它让我们陷入沉默，我们的运作更多地出于恐惧，我们不再提出想法。我们不敢大声说出错误或潜在的失误，因为我们害怕遭到反弹。
Now, Rootness doesn't just have consequences for us, it can have downstream consequences as well on other people. The psychologist Amir Arreas has found that incivility can affect the performance of medical professionals. Can you describe what he's found? Yeah, well, one of the studies that I love that they did was surgical teams in Israel that were exposed to rudeness, meaning they overheard that they were not doing a procedure
现在，粗鲁不仅对我们产生后果，还可能对其他人产生连锁反应。心理学家阿米尔·阿雷亚斯发现，无礼会影响医疗专业人员的表现。你能描述一下他的发现吗？是的，我喜欢他们的研究之一是关于以色列的外科团队，他们接触过粗鲁行为，意思是他们无意中听到自己某项手术做得
well enough. Those medical teams performed worse on all of their diagnostics and all of the procedures they did. And they found that this was mainly because they stopped sharing information as much and they stopped seeking help from these people on their teams performing the surgery. And I understand that these researchers have found that even watching someone else get treated
不够好。那些医疗团队在所有的诊断和进行的所有手术中表现都更差。他们发现这主要是因为他们不再那么多地分享信息，也不再向团队中负责手术的人寻求帮助。据我所知，这些研究人员发现，甚至只是看着别人受到不好的对待，
badly reduced the ability of some of these medical professionals to think flexibly about a patient's condition. Yeah. And so that's some of these medical professionals to think flexibly about a patient's condition. Yeah, and so that's some of their recent research that shows that they get anchored almost on an idea. And when they've been exposed to rudeness, they have a really hard time pivoting to consider anything else. So it almost is this idea of lack of creativity, you know, they can't even be open to any new information because they're stuck. And so moving forward and performing well, considering
也会降低其中一些医疗专业人员对患者病情进行灵活思考的能力。是的。因此，这是他们最近的一些研究，表明他们几乎会固着在一个想法上。当他们接触过粗鲁行为后，他们很难转变思路去考虑任何其他事情。所以这几乎就是缺乏创造力的表现，你知道，他们甚至无法对任何新信息保持开放，因为他们被卡住了。因此，要向前发展并表现良好，考虑
other ideas, they're just not capable of. I mean, what strikes me from the example you're giving about the study here in Israel, you know, suggests that there are downstream effects of instability and rootiness. So it's not just the people within the workplace who are affected, but the people now who are coming in contact with the workplace, the consumers, the patients at a hospital,
其他想法，他们根本做不到。我的意思是，你所举的关于以色列这项研究的例子让我震惊的是，它表明不稳定和粗鲁具有下游效应。所以不仅是工作场所内的人受到影响，现在那些与工作场所接触的人（消费者、医院的病人）也受到了影响，
it seems as if rootiness can have these spiraling effects on larger and larger numbers of people. One of the reasons I went into studying this is because I felt like it not only colored people's work lives, but they took it home with them. It affected their personal lives as well. People just, they became a smaller version of themselves.
看起来粗鲁会对越来越多的人产生这种螺旋式的扩散效应。我开始研究这个课题的原因之一，是因为我觉得它不仅给人们的工作生活涂上了阴霾，而且他们还把它带回了家。它也影响了他们的个人生活。人们只是变得不再那么大度。
They became probably more frustrated, more angry, more depressed. It affected their personal relationships in really important ways. It definitely does flow through social networks and spreads in very powerful ways. You know, Christine, we've seen YouTube and Twitter and Facebook a full of examples of moments that have gone viral where people have behaved rudely and their, you know, their behaviors, their actions, their words are basically spread far and wide on the internet. But I think what you're saying is that there's a different kind of virality that rudeness and instability can have. It can have downstream effects on the people who witnessed that instability and then further downstream effects on other people whom they come in contact with.
他们可能变得更加沮丧、更加愤怒、更加消沉。它以非常重要的方式影响了他们的个人关系。它确实会通过社交网络流动，并以非常强大的方式传播。你知道，克里斯蒂，我们看到YouTube、推特和脸书上到处都是病毒式传播的时刻的例子，人们表现得很粗鲁，他们的行为、行动、话语基本上在互联网上广泛传播。但我认为你的意思是，粗鲁和不稳定可以产生另一种不同的病毒式传播。它会对目睹这种不稳定的人产生下游效应，进而对与他们接触的其他人员产生进一步的下游效应。
Yeah, that's what we find in our research is both within the workplace as well as outside of it. When you witness in civility, you pass it forward. And so if you're seeing it anywhere online on the media, you will likely become a carrier of this virus and pass it forward with whoever you come in contact with. And a lot of that is unintentional. When we come back, is there a way to put the genie back in the bottle? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
是的，这就是我们在研究中发现的，无论是在工作场所内部还是外部。当你目睹无礼行为时，你就会把它传递下去。因此，如果你在网上或媒体上的任何地方看到它，你很可能会成为这种病毒的携带者，并将其传递给你接触的任何人。其中很多都是无意的。稍后回来，有什么办法能把神灯里的妖怪再装回去吗？您正在收听的是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。
Behavioral scientist Christine Porat studies Incivility. She's found it has powerful and long lasting effects on our thinking, on our emotions, and on our well-being. Although it's difficult to get precise numbers on this, it's hard to escape the feeling that Incivility is on the rise. What can we do about it? When people treat us rudely, our first impulse might be to respond in kind. But Christine says it's a good idea to reflect that at least sometimes, rudeness can be unintentional.
行为科学家克里斯蒂·波拉思研究无礼行为。她发现它对我们的思维、情绪和福祉有着强大而持久的影响。尽管很难得到这方面的准确数据，但人们很难摆脱无礼现象正在上升的感觉。我们能对此做些什么呢？当人们粗鲁地对待我们时，我们的第一冲动可能是以牙还牙。但克里斯蒂说，反思一下是一个好主意，至少有时粗鲁可能是无意的。
When we ask why people are rude, only 4% said because it's fun and they can get away with it. I think the vast majority of people have no idea that what they're doing is hurting people or making them feel small in some way. And so I believe it stems from a lack of self-awareness. In her work with groups and organizations, Christine sometimes draws on an old idea from psychology, the Johari window. The psychologist Joseph Lought and Harrington Ingram divided a square into quadrants, like a four-pained window. One paying represents things we know about ourselves that others know as well.
当我们问人们为什么粗鲁时，只有4%的人说是为了好玩并且能逃脱惩罚。我认为绝大多数人根本不知道他们的所作所为正在伤害别人或以某种方式让别人觉得自己很渺小。因此，我认为这源于缺乏自我意识。在与团队和组织的合作中，克里斯蒂有时会借鉴心理学的一个老概念——约哈里之窗。心理学家约瑟夫·勒夫和哈林顿·英格拉姆将一个正方形划分为四个象限，就像一扇四块玻璃的窗户。一块玻璃代表我们对自己了解、别人也了解的事情。
A second looks at secrets, things that we know about ourselves that others do not know. Another looks at elements of ourselves that are unknown both to us and to others. Christine focuses on a final pain. Things that others know about us, that we don't know about ourselves. The jahari window is really this idea of what we know about ourselves, what we do not know about ourselves, what others know about us, and what others do not know about us. And so we're really trying
第二个象限关注秘密，也就是我们自己知道而别人不知道的事情。另一个象限关注我们自己和别人都不知道的自我元素。克里斯蒂专注于最后一块玻璃。别人了解我们，而我们自己却不了解的事情。约哈里之窗实际上就是关于我们对自己了解什么、我们对自己不了解什么、别人对我们了解什么以及别人对我们不了解什么的理念。因此，我们真的在努力
to uncover our blind spots around what's known to others but is not known to ourselves because these blind spots are really what's affecting how we're behaving in ways that are often hurtful to others. in ways that are often hurtful to others. You've collaborated with the organizational psychologist, Tasha Eurek, and she studies how self-aware people are. So how self-aware are people? I mean, relative to how self-aware they think there. Yeah, not very self-aware. So she has not at all, there's a huge gap.
揭开我们在他人眼中已知但在我们自己眼中却未知的盲区，因为这些盲区正是影响我们行为方式的真正原因，而这些行为往往会伤害他人。往往会伤害他人。你曾与组织心理学家塔莎·尤里克合作，她研究人们的自我意识有多强。那么人们的自我意识有多强？我是说，相对于他们自己认为的自我意识而言。是的，自我意识不是很强。所以她认为完全没有，这里面有巨大的差距。
So she has found that 95% of people believe that they're self-aware. We have a good sense of our strengths and how we're perceived. However, she has found that only 10 to 15% of people actually are self-aware. And so 80% of us are fooling ourselves on any given day about what people think of us. And we tend to bias at all in the positive direction. Marshall Goldsmith who coaches a lot of leaders and he talks about this idea of we like to play a highlight reel of our successes in our minds. And so we kind of anchor in on the positives and how we affect others. And we, our blind spots are usually
因此她发现，95%的人认为自己很有自我意识。我们对自己的长处以及自己被别人感知的方式有很好的把握。然而，她发现只有10%到15%的人实际上具备自我意识。因此，在任何特定的一天里，我们当中有80%的人都在自欺欺人，以为别人是如何看待我们的。而且我们往往会把所有的偏见都朝积极的方向倾斜。教练了许多领导者的马歇尔·戈德史密斯谈到了这样一个观点：我们喜欢在脑海中播放自己成功的精彩集锦。因此，我们倾向于锁定积极的方面以及我们如何影响他人。而我们的盲区通常
on the negatives and how we're affecting people in harmful ways or ways that may even hurt us. I understand, Christine, that you once had an encounter with a friend who revealed to you something about your own behavior that you were not aware of. What did he tell you about your conversational style? So he told me that I had a tendency to interrupt or to jump in when someone else was speaking. And that was something that I didn't realize that I did. So if there was a pregnant pause in our conversation, I was happy to help him along, finish his thoughts or insert my question. And so when I got this feedback, I was really surprised.
在消极方面，以及我们如何以有害的方式或甚至可能伤害我们的方式影响人们。克里斯蒂，我听说你曾经偶遇一位朋友，他向你透露了你连自己都没意识到的关于你自身行为的一些事情。他跟你说了关于你的对话风格的什么事？所以他告诉我，当别人在说话时，我有打断或插话的倾向。这是我没有意识到自己会做的事情。因此，如果在我们的对话中出现了一段意味深长的停顿，我很乐意帮他把话说完，或者插进我的问题。所以当我得到这个反馈时，我真的很惊讶。
And did it feel like there was any truth to it? It did. And in fact, I think the funny thing was as he was telling me this, I was ready to jump in with the Y or the defensiveness, which had him laughing and me laughing. And, you know, if there was any doubt that was cleared up right away in the moment. Christine talked earlier about the educator and coach, Marshall Goldsmith. He was a pioneer in what's called 360-degree feedback. It's a structured system some leaders have used to solicit the opinions of a wide range of colleagues and subordinates. As it turns out, even people who teach others to overcome their blind spots have blind spots of their own. So he actually collected 360 degree feedback at the consulting firm he ran and he has a reputation for being a great guy and a giver. And so he was really upset by the fact that the feedback he
感觉它有任何真实性吗？有的。事实上，我觉得有趣的是，当他告诉我这些时，我已经准备好用“为什么”或防御性的话语来打断他了，这让他笑了，我也笑了。而且，你知道，如果有任何怀疑的话，当时就在那一刻被彻底澄清了。克里斯蒂早些时候谈到了教育家和教练马歇尔·戈德史密斯。他是所谓的360度反馈的先驱。这是一个结构化系统，一些领导者用它来征求广泛的同事和下属的意见。事实证明，即使是那些教导他人克服盲区的人，自己也有盲区。所以他实际上在他经营的咨询公司收集了360度反馈，而且他以是个好人和乐于奉献的人而闻名。因此，他收到的反馈是“他有在背后说别人坏话的倾向”，这让他感到非常沮丧。
got was he had a tendency to talk badly about people behind their backs. And he felt terrible, but he also couldn't think of any times where he had done this. And so he challenged his employees. He said $10 anytime you call me out on this. On day one, he said he was down $50 by lunchtime. And he locked himself in his office and decided, that's enough. No more for today.
他感觉糟糕透了，但他同时也想不出自己什么时候做过这种事。因此，他向他的员工下了战书。他说，任何时候只要你们指出我的这个问题，我就给你们10美元。第一天，他说到吃午饭时他就已经输了50美元。他把自己锁在办公室里决定：“够了。今天到此为止。”
And then he said he improved, you know, it was $30 and then $10. And so his point was not that we have to put a tax on our own behavior, but even the leading coaching guru that came up with 360 feedback and everything, you know, he wasn't aware of behaviors that he certainly wasn't proud of. I mean, it was the opposite of the effect that he wanted to have. Yet, he was completely unaware. He couldn't think
然后他说他进步了，你知道，先是30美元，然后是10美元。所以他的观点并不是说我们必须对自己的行为征税，而是连提出360度反馈等概念的顶尖教练大师，你知道，他也没有意识到那些他绝对不引以为傲的行为。我的意思是，这与他想要达到的效果截然相反。然而，他却完全没有意识到。他根本想不出
of a time where he had done it. It even showed that we need the help of others to try to uncover some of this awareness for us so that we can improve. The research at Josh Misner at North Idaho College has another idea on how you can increase the amount of feedback that you get. And his idea has now been taken and is being used by organizational psychologists. Tell me about the dinner of truth. So the dinner of truth is that you ask a friend or a colleague out for dinner and you ask them, you know, what's one of the most annoying habits that I have? Or what is something that I do that, you know, hurts me or you or it leads to my ineffectiveness?
自己曾经做过这种事。这甚至表明，我们需要借助他人的帮助来试图为我们揭开其中一些意识，以便我们能够改进。北爱达荷学院的乔什·米斯纳的研究提出了另一个关于如何增加你获得的反馈量的想法。他的想法现在已经被采纳并被组织心理学家所使用。跟我讲讲“真理晚宴”。所以“真理晚宴”就是你邀请一位朋友或同事共进晚餐，然后问他们：“我身上最烦人的习惯之一是什么？”或者“我做过什么事情，你知道的，伤害了我或你，或者导致我的效率低下？”
And ideally you sit there and you take the feedback and you use it to move you forward. And although people like Tasha Yerke have told me that they thought, I'm not gonna get real feedback from this friend, that in fact they get super valuable feedback and it's a way to move them forward. But you know, it's not easy to do in the sense of a lot of people
理想情况下，你坐在那里接受反馈，并用它来推动自己前进。尽管像塔莎·尤里克这样的人曾对我说，他们认为“我不会从这个朋友那里得到真实的反馈”，但事实上他们得到了超级有价值的反馈，这是推动他们前进的一种方式。但你知道，这并不容易做到，因为很多人
are fearful of what they might hear. I want to spend a little time talking about how we might respond to incivility that's directed at us, how we can keep it from hijacking our bodies and our minds. As we've seen, confronting rudeness with rudeness doesn't seem like a very good solution, avoiding the perpetrator of rudeness often doesn't work very well.
对他们可能会听到的话感到恐惧。我想花一点时间谈谈我们该如何应对针对我们的无礼行为，我们如何防止它劫持我们的身体和大脑。正如我们所见，用粗鲁来对抗粗鲁似乎并不是一个很好的解决方案，避开粗鲁的施加者通常也效果不佳。
You say that one alternative is to change your own frame and to focus on the future. What do you mean by this? Well, I think it's important that you control what you can control. And usually that means just yourself. And the research shows we found that the one antidote to instability is a sense of thriving, like a sense of feeling like you're moving forward. And so it's about getting unstuck. And
你说的一个替代方案是改变你自己的框架并专注于未来。你这是什么意思？嗯，我认为控制你能控制的东西很重要。通常这意味着只有你自己。研究表明，我们发现对抗不稳定的唯一解药是一种蓬勃发展的感觉，比如感觉你在向前迈进。所以关键在于摆脱困境。
for a lot of people it's focusing on taking care of themselves, like for example exercising or something like that. What you want to do is you want to do something that builds hope that helps you focus on moving forward in a positive way, not getting dragged down about your past. The other aspect is a sense of vitality or energy and so there are lots of ways to potentially achieve this. It could be activities like getting involved in your community, coaching, volunteering, choosing something that makes you feel smarter, stronger, or more interesting, that really clears your mind or feeds your soul.
对许多人来说，这专注于照顾好自己，比如锻炼之类的。你想做的是做一些能建立希望的事情，帮助你以积极的方式专注于向前迈进，而不是被你的过去拖垮。另一个方面是活力或能量，所以有很多方法可以潜在地实现这一点。这可以是一些活动，比如参与你的社区活动、教练辅导、志愿服务，选择一些让你觉得自己更聪明、更强大或更有趣的事情，这真的能清醒你的头脑或滋养你的灵魂。
And we talked a lot about instability as a virus. And your defense really depends to a large extent on your ability to manage your soul. And we talked a lot about insability as a virus. And your defense really depends to a large extent on your ability to manage your energy. And my research suggests that many of the factors that help prevent illness, like good nutrition, sleep, stress management, can also help ward off insabilities, noxious effects. So in some ways, to stick with disease and energy, what I think I hear you say is if you're in noxious effects. So in some ways to stick with disease and energy, what I think I hear you say is if you're confronted by a virus, yes, you can go looking for the antidote to the virus, but perhaps the better solution
我们讨论了很多关于不稳定是一种病毒的话题。你的防线在很大程度上取决于你管理能量的能力。我的研究表明，许多有助于预防疾病的因素，如良好的营养、睡眠、压力管理，也可以帮助抵御不稳定的有害影响。所以从某种程度上说，为了延续疾病和能量的比喻，我想我听到你说的是，如果你面对一种病毒，是的，你可以去寻找对抗这种病毒的解药，但也许更好的解决方案
is just to have a stronger immune system. Yeah, I think that's exactly right. And there are ways that we can do that, including even building positive relationships inside or outside of work. Or if this happens to work, we encourage people to focus on thriving outside of work, because by doing things that make you feel good outside of the workplace, you actually bring a stronger, more resilient self inside the workplace. So I think that's helpful.
只是拥有一个更强大的免疫系统。是的，我认为这完全正确。我们可以通过多种方式做到这一点，包括甚至在工作内部或外部建立积极的关系。或者如果这发生在工作场所，我们鼓励人们专注于工作之外的蓬勃发展，因为通过做那些让你在工作场所之外感觉良好的事情，你实际上会在工作场所带入一个更强大、更有韧性的自我。所以我认为这很有帮助。
I understand that you're working with nurses to teach them strategies to thrive. Many, many nurses report, you know, dealing with a significant amount of instability and rudeness in the workplace, especially perhaps during the COVID-19 pandemic. There have been Asian American nurses who've been attacked by patients about, you know, quote, bringing the virus from China and nurses report being regularly in the receiving end of bad treatment from physicians, describe for me the work that you're doing with nurses and the effects that you're finding it has.
我知道你一直在与护士合作，教导她们繁荣发展的策略。许多护士表示，她们在工作中处理着大量的无序和无礼现象，尤其可能在新冠疫情期间。有些亚裔美国护士遭到患者袭击，理由是她们把病毒从中国带过来，而且护士们还报告说经常受到医生的恶劣对待。请描述一下你与护士合作开展的工作以及你发现它所产生的影响。
So one of the things that we're coaching them on that we've seen evidence and experiments that by what they call self-distancing. So this idea of kind of pulling back out of the moment and it's almost like, you know, asking someone to step out and watch the scene as a movie unfolding. And so trying to take a step back from the event and trying to get a better and bigger picture perspective on it. So for example, one way you can do this is ask, okay, in five years, what kind of effect
因此，我们对她们进行的一项指导是基于我们看到的证据和实验，即他们所说的“自我疏离”。也就是从当下抽离出来的这种想法，这几乎就像是要求某人退后一步，看着这个场景像一部正在展开的电影一样。因此，试图从事件中退后一步，并试图对其获得更好、更宏观的视角。举个例子，你可以这样做：问问自己，五年后，这件事
is this gonna have on you? So we found that self-distancing makes people more objective and less emotionally involved in the encounter and this can help individuals find better solutions in the moment and moving forward. So if they have the capability to distance themselves from the stressor, let's say this rude encounter, they're able to, let's say, serve the patient better in the moment, or come back to the patient more quickly
会对你产生什么影响？因此我们发现，自我疏离能让人在遭遇时更加客观，减少情绪卷入，这可以帮助个人在当下及未来找到更好的解决方案。因此，如果她们有能力将自己与压力源（比方说这次无礼的遭遇）隔离开来，她们就能在当下更好地为患者服务，或者更快地回到患者身边，
without kind of taking it out on them or just being really wrapped up in what to make of the situation. We talked earlier about how when you've experienced in civility, you've often found it hard to set it aside and to basically focus on other things. In some ways, in civility and rudeness can hijack the mind and make it very difficult
而不会把气撒在他们身上，或者只是过分纠结于如何看待这种情况。我们之前讨论过，当你经历无礼时，通常会发现很难将其搁置，并基本上专注于其他事情。在某种程度上，无礼和粗鲁会劫持大脑，使人很难
to focus on other things. And so, one surprisingly, peopleity and rudeness can hijack the mind and make it very difficult to focus on other things. And so, one surprisingly, people who experience rudeness end up persevering on the thing that happened, on the root thing that happened, on the, you know, the root thing that was set to them. And partly, I think what you're suggesting is actually so hard, because what you're saying is that that kind of perseveration, in fact, is not useful. In fact, it's not helpful. that kind of perseveration in fact is not useful. In fact, it's not helpful. Yeah, I think it is extremely challenging
专注于其他事情。因此，令人惊讶的是，经历无礼的人最终会执着于发生的事情，执着于发生的那件无礼的事情，执着于对他们所说的话。部分原因，我认为你所建议的实际上是如此困难，因为你所说的那种执着事实上是没有用的。事实上，这并无帮助。这种执着事实上是没有用处。事实上，它并没有帮助。是的，我认为这是极其具有挑战性的
to get that advice, but it leads to a lot better results and in the case of nurses, you know, when patient safety is at risk, I think it's imperative that they find coping strategies so that they can attend to people, you know, in a way that doesn't take them off track, especially for long periods of time. So we're trying to find interventions or things that help them, not only cope with it, but recover quickly and move them forward.
去接受这个建议，但它能带来好得多结果。以护士为例，当患者安全处于危险之中时，我认为她们必须找到应对策略，以便能够照顾他人，而不会偏离轨道，特别是不会持续很长时间。因此，我们正试图寻找干预措施或方法，不仅帮助她们应对，还能让她们迅速恢复并继续前进。
I mean, I also think that that idea of thriving is really crucial for them because they've been under such challenging circumstances and strain for a long time that it's really important that they take care of themselves. Just coming in is physically ready as possible because it's going to help them be able to regulate and respond best to anything that they may deal with that day. I'm wondering if people push back on you when you give them this advice, because I suspect that many people who have experienced incivility seek justice more than anything else. They actually want the wrong door to make a man's. And you're telling them the best way to deal with
我的意思是，我也认为繁荣发展的想法对她们至关重要，因为她们长期处于如此具有挑战性的环境和压力之下，照顾好自己真的非常重要。以尽可能最佳的身体状态投入工作，因为这将帮助她们能够调节并对那天可能遇到的任何事情做出最佳反应。我想知道，当你给他们这个建议时，是否有人会抗拒，因为我怀疑许多经历过无礼对待的人比什么都更渴望正义。他们实际上希望做错事的人做出补偿。而你却告诉他们，处理这件事的最佳方式
this really is to not pay attention to it, to move on with your day to try and find other things in your life that you're engaged with that make you happy. Do people respond to that advice well, Christine? You know, generally I think they do. The nice thing is you're betting on yourself and not betting on someone else changing and it's the vast majority of these situations at work, even if they told the organization, the organization acted on that, which is rare. You know, it still isn't likely
实际上是不要理会它，继续过好你的一天，试着寻找生活中其他让你投入并感到快乐的事情。人们对这个建议反应好吗，克里斯蒂汀？你知道，通常我认为他们反应不错。好消息是，你在对自己进行投资，而不是指望别人改变。在绝大多数工作场所的这些情况下，即使她们告诉了组织，组织对此采取了行动，这也是罕见的。你知道，这仍然不太可能
that that person's gonna change completely. And so really what you're asking them is to focus on themselves and bet on themselves in their future. And at least for myself, like I like that message because that gives me some power and and otherwise really disempowering situation. I want to look at some complexities when it comes to incivility. You've written what matters is not whether people actually were disrespected or treated insensitively, but whether they felt
那个人会彻底改变。所以，你真正要求她们做的是关注自己，为自己和未来下注。至少对我来说，我喜欢这个信息，因为它在原本非常无权无势的情况下赋予了我一些力量。我想看看涉及无礼的一些复杂性。你写过，重要的不是人们是否真的被不尊重或被无礼对待，而是他们是否感到
disrespected. Incivility is in the eyes of the recipient. Now, I can see the virtue of taking people's concerns about incivility seriously, but I can also see some people saying, hang on a minute, if each person can decide for themselves what is rude and what is not rude, how do we come to a shared understanding of instability? I mean, so someone who's from a very polite culture, let's say from the US South, could come to a place like New York City and say, everyone in this town is really rude. Yeah, it's what makes it really tricky. And that's why providing information to people about how things are affecting you, at least if that's
被不尊重。无礼存在于接受者的眼中。现在，我能看到认真对待人们关于无礼的担忧的价值，但我也可以看到有些人会说，等一下，如果每个人都可以自己决定什么是粗鲁，什么不是粗鲁，我们如何才能对无礼达成共识？我的意思是，一个来自非常礼貌文化的人，比方说来自美国南部，可能会来到像纽约市这样地方，说这个镇上的每个人都很粗鲁。是的，这正是让它变得非常棘手的原因。这就是为什么向人们提供关于事物如何影响你的信息，至少如果那是
someone you work with regularly, is helpful. But I mean the US is such a big place and there are such differences behind how we communicate. And then certainly if you think about globally. So I think that's what makes it so challenging. Having worked with some firms like the UN or International Monetary Fund where they have employees from 183 countries, I mean, that makes it really tough to come up with norms for communicating
一个你经常共事的人，是有帮助的。但我的意思是美国是一个如此大的地方，我们沟通的方式背后存在着如此大的差异。如果考虑到全球范围的话就更是如此。所以我认为这就是它如此具有挑战性的原因。曾与一些机构合作过，比如联合国或国际货币基金组织，他们拥有来自183个国家的员工，我的意思是，这使得制定沟通规范或我们如何对待彼此的规范变得非常困难
or how we treat each other. So sometime ago I came by this clip of an incident that took place on a Delta Airlines flight between Tampa and Atlanta, a man and a woman got into a fight. It started when the woman was told she'd have to wait for the beverage cart to move before she could take her seat. And then it quickly escalated into a fight about whether to wear face masks. Soon insults were flying back and forth and eventually the woman threw a punch. What I find striking about this clip Christine is that both parties seem to feel like they have victims of incivility. So if I think that wearing a mask saves lives during a pandemic, I can see your refusal
或者我们如何对待彼此。所以一段时间前，我偶然看到了坦帕飞往亚特兰大的一架达美航空航班上发生的一起事件的视频片段，一名男子和一名女子发生争执。事情起因是该女子被告知必须等待饮料车移动才能入座。随后迅速升级为关于是否佩戴口罩的争执。很快侮辱之词满天飞，最终该女子挥拳相向。克里斯蒂汀，这段视频最让我震惊的是，双方似乎都觉得自己是不礼貌行为的受害者。因此，如果我认为在大流行期间戴口罩可以挽救生命，我就会认为你拒绝
to wear a mask as the height of rudeness. And if you think wearing a mask is not necessary, you can see me as being an obnoxious, busy body. Is it possible that in many confrontations both parties feel like they have victims of instability? Yes, because we may lack self-awareness or simply disagree with whatever we did that they thought was rude. There's definitely a likelihood of misperceptions. And I think a lot of times, this happens even more so over email, because over email you don't have a person's tone or their non-verbals. And so I think that there's a lot of misunderstandings where
戴口罩是极其粗鲁的行为。如果你认为没有必要戴口罩，你可能会认为我是一个令人讨厌、好管闲事的人。在许多对抗中，双方是否都觉得自己是不礼貌行为的受害者？是的，因为我们可能缺乏自我意识，或者只是不同意他们认为粗鲁的任何行为。绝对存在产生误解的可能性。而且我认为很多时候，这种情况在电子邮件中更是如此，因为通过电子邮件你无法感受到一个人的语气或非语言表达。所以我认为有很多误解，其中
you assume that someone may be me rude and may then respond with a rude email or an accusatory tone. And so then it kind of gets you in a negative spiral when in fact some of it could have stemmed from a misunderstanding. I'm wondering if there's a bit of a contradiction here, because on the one hand, I think we want to take people seriously when they say, I'm really feeling like I have been treated badly. You don't want to dismiss that. On the other hand, we're also saying that people are not very self-aware and not quite aware of what's happening in situations. There seems to be a disconnect between those two things. How do we simultaneously accept people at face value when they say,
你可能会假设某人可能很粗鲁，然后用粗鲁的电子邮件或指责的语气回应。所以这有点让你陷入负面螺旋，而事实上其中一些可能源于误解。我想知道这里是否存在某种矛盾，因为一方面，当人们说“我真的觉得自己受到了不好的对待”时，我认为我们希望认真对待他们。你不想忽视这一点。另一方面，我们也说人们并没有多少自我意识，对情况中正在发生的事情不太清楚。这两者之间似乎存在脱节。我们如何能一方面全盘接受人们的说法，当他们说时，
I believe that I have been treated rudely and also taken to account that perhaps they are not self-aware about the role that they have brought to the conversation like this incident that took place on the plane. I think feedback is crucial, meaning if you're in a workplace, let's say, providing people feedback around how they're perceived and what their role is in an incident. Radical candor, I think if you can create cultures where people are radically candid with each other, the saying is clear but kind. I think that that's a good thing to shoot for. It doesn't solve the problem in the plane.
“我相信我受到了粗鲁的对待”，同时又考虑到他们可能没有意识到自己在这样的对话中所扮演的角色，就像飞机上发生的这起事件一样。我认为反馈是至关重要的，这意味着如果你在一个工作场所，比方说，围绕人们如何被感知以及他们在事件中扮演什么角色向他们提供反馈。激进的坦诚，我认为如果你能创造一种人们彼此激进坦诚的文化，俗话说就是明确而友善。我认为这是一个很好的目标。它并没有解决飞机上的问题。
But I think if in communities or families, if we can come at it with that perspective, I hope that that's helpful. Otherwise, it just seems like we're stuck in a negative cycle. You know, some people might say, you know, perhaps we're setting the bar too high. And if we are worrying so much about how the things we're going to be saying are going to be misinterpreted or overinterpreted by other people, it'll cause people to walk on eggshells. So they'll be hesitant to say what's on their mind,
但我想如果在社群或家庭中，如果我们能以这种视角来对待它，我希望这会有所帮助。否则，这看起来就像我们陷入了负面循环。你知道，有些人可能会说，也许我们把标准定得太高了。如果我们如此担心我们要说的话将如何被其他人误解或过度解读，就会导致人们如履薄冰。因此，他们会犹豫是否说出心中的想法，
to speak there, to actually offer feedback in a candidate fashion, to tell people what's going on, to make jokes, to be casual. How do you respond to this? Because I feel like there is a delicate balance here between essentially suppressing how people talk and walk in the world, and basically giving people carte blanche to basically say and do whatever they feel like doing. Yeah, I think it is a tough balance to strike in reality. I think that if you can create this culture where there is care and concern for others,
畅所欲言，以坦诚的方式提供反馈，告诉人们发生了什么，开玩笑，表现得随性。你如何回应这一点？因为我觉得这里存在着一种微妙的平衡，一方面基本上是压抑人们的说话和生活方式，另一方面基本上是给予人们全权委托去说和做他们觉得想做的任何事情。是的，我认为在现实中这是一个很难把握的平衡。我认为如果你能创造这样一种文化，其中包含对他人的关怀和关心，
that that idea of radical candor is so much easier and you don't get caught up worrying about or processing the intentions behind something. You just let it kind of roll off someone's back. You just move forward. And so I think the sweet spot is this idea of you care personally and you feel comfortable challenging directly.
激进坦诚的理念就会容易得多，你也不会纠结于担心或处理某事背后的意图。你只是让它从某人身上顺其自然地滑落。你只是向前迈进。所以我认为最佳平衡点就是这种理念：你真切关心，并且乐于直接提出挑战。
Because I think we want that feedback. I don't think we want to sugarcoat things. I don't think we want a situation where we're afraid to tell the truth or to speak up about potential issues. I think we've got to create these environments where people feel a sense of trust and respect, you know, where they feel what's called psychologically safe. And that's where the magic can really happen
因为我认为我们需要这种反馈。我不认为我们需要粉饰事情。我不认为我们需要这样一种情况：我们害怕说出真相或大声说出潜在的问题。我认为我们必须创造这样的环境，让人们感受到信任和尊重，也就是他们感受到所谓的心理安全。这就是奇迹真正发生的地方
that people can be their most productive, creative, helpful, healthy selves. We've looked at a lot of downsides of instability, but as I was reading your work, I was wondering, do you ever think we should make exceptions for instability in some cases? I'm reminded of the famous line, well-behaved women seldom make history. And the truth is that there are many activists in many causes
人们可以成为最具生产力、创造力、乐于助人、最健康的自己。我们已经看过了无礼的许多弊端，但在阅读你的作品时，我一直在想，你是否认为我们在某些情况下应该对无礼破例？我想起了那句名言：表现乖巧的女性很少创造历史。事实是，有许多活动家在许多事业中
who have behaved in ways that their opponents might describe as rude, but in fact would argue that they were on the right side of history. Yeah, I'm sure that there are examples of that. I think that if you're strong in your convictions, then that is something that you have to weigh the potential costs of how you're going to be perceived and move forward in the best way possible. I also think that some of this comes
他们的行为方式可能会被对手描述为粗鲁，但实际上他们会认为自己站在历史正确的一边。是的，我确信有这样的例子。我认为如果你坚信自己的信念，那么这就是你必须权衡自己被感知到的潜在成本并以尽可能最佳方式前进的事情。我也认为其中一些
back to leading authentically. And so some people are considered rude when they definitely don't mean to be. So again, improving yourself awareness around that could lead to you being most effective. But it's hard for me to kind of think about specific behaviors that I would say, oh, definitely never rude or always worth doing it that way. I think that probably you're best served by weighing it
回归到真诚领导。因此，有些人被认为粗鲁，但他们绝对不是故意这样的。因此，再次提高你在这方面的自我意识可以使你最高效。但我很难想到我可以说“这绝对永远不粗鲁”或“这样总是值得做”的具体行为。我认为你最好还是在当下权衡
in the moment and trying to explain yourself. I think some of the research that has struck me is if you preface negative feedback with something along the lines of, I care about you and I think you can do better. And people are far less defensive. They respond, I think it's 40% better to that. And I think that if you have planted the seeds
并试着解释自己。我认为让我印象深刻的一些研究是，如果你在负面意见前加上类似这样的话：“我在乎你，我认为你能做得更好。”人们的防御心会大大降低。他们对这种说法的反应，我认为要好40%。而且我认为如果你已经播下了种子
and shown people that you care about them and that you tend to be respectful, then you're much less likely to be really hurt if they slip up from time to time or really hold it against them. And they're famous leaders that have apologized hurt if they slip up from time to time or really hold it against them. And they're famous leaders that have apologized for such incidents and, you know, been forgiven by people because they feel like they have a pattern of treating people respectfully.
并向人们展示你在乎他们，而且你往往是尊重他们的，那么即使他们偶尔失误，你也不太可能真正受到伤害或真正记恨他们。有名的领导人曾为这种事件道歉，你知道，得到了人们的原谅，因为他们觉得他们有尊重对待人们的模式。
And the truth is, we all slip up from time to time. But if we've invested in our relationships, usually these are things that we can recover from hopefully quickly and without too much effort. It seems like very few people would argue with the idea that we'd all be better off if we could have more positive, affirmative experiences and relationships, but I was struck by one idea
事实是，我们所有人有时都会犯错。但如果我们投资于我们的人际关系，通常这些都是我们可以恢复的，希望能够迅速且无需付出太多努力。似乎很少有人会反驳这样的观点：如果我们能有更多积极、肯定经历和人际关系，我们都会过得更好，但我被一个想法深深打动了
that you've advanced. You've reached back to the work of an early 20th century scholar named Charles Horton Kooley. You find that he had an idea that is especially useful to think about as we're thinking about in civility. What was his argument? So he talked about the looking glass self. And the idea is that it explains that we use others' expressions like smiles or behaviors
你提出的这个观点。你追溯了20世纪初学者查尔斯·霍顿·库利的著作。你发现他的一个观点在思考无礼时特别有用。他的论点是什么？所以他谈到了“镜中自我”。这个想法解释了我们如何利用他人的表情（如微笑）或行为
like acknowledging us and reactions like listening to us or insulting us to define ourselves. So how we believe others see us shapes who we are. We ride a wave of pride or get swallowed in a sea of embarrassment based on brief interactions that signal, respect, or disrespect. Individuals feel valued and powerful when respected. So I believe that civility lifts people. Whereas in civility holds people down. It makes people feel small. And so we will be healthier, more productive, lead more fulfilling lives when we are civil
（如承认我们）以及反应（如倾听我们或侮辱我们）来定义自我。因此，我们认为别人如何看待我们塑造了我们是谁。我们乘着自豪的浪潮，或者在简短的互动中被尴尬的海洋吞没，这些互动标志着尊重或不尊重。当受到尊重时，个人会感到有价值和强大。因此，我相信文明能提升人。而无礼则压抑人。它让人觉得自己很渺小。因此，当我们行事文明时，我们会更健康、更有生产力、过上更充实的生活，
that our communities will be healthier, more productive, and more creative, and you'll allow members to achieve their potential much more if they live and work in more respectful cultures where people can really thrive. Christine Porath is a behavioral scientist at Georgetown University. She's the author of the book's Mastering Civility, a manifesto for the workplace, and with Christine Pearson, the cost of bad behavior. Christine Porath, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
我们的社区将更健康、更有生产力、更有创造力，如果他们生活和工作在更相互尊重的文化中，人们能够真正繁荣发展，你将极大地允许成员发挥他们的潜力。克里斯蒂汀·波拉斯是乔治敦大学的行为科学家。她是《掌控文明：职场宣言》一书的作者，并与克里斯蒂汀·皮尔逊合著了《恶劣行为的代价》。克里斯蒂汀·波拉斯，感谢你今天加入“隐秘大脑”。谢谢。隐秘大脑由隐秘大脑传媒制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Dina Amand of Lawrence, Kansas. Dina is a financial supporter of Hidden Brain. She recently sent a note to share that she discovered a show several years ago after it
我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是“隐秘大脑”的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是来自堪萨斯州劳伦斯的迪娜·阿曼德。迪娜是“隐秘大脑”的财务支持者。她最近发来便条分享说，她在几年前发现了这个节目，当时是由
was recommended by a friend. She writes, I went back and listened to every single episode. I never let myself get more than a week or so behind. Thank you so much for your interest in the show, Dina, and for your support. We're so grateful. If you'd like to join Dina in helping us make Hidden Brain, you can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that site is support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
朋友推荐的。她写道，我回头听了每一个单集。我从不让自己落后超过一周左右。非常感谢你对本节目的兴趣，迪娜，也感谢你的支持。我们非常感激。如果你想加入迪娜帮助我们制作“隐秘大脑”，你可以在 support.hiddenbrain.org 上进行。再次强调，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回头见。此单集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。